and she's going to continue talking
about the impacting when I work with uh
today I should talk about suggestions
thank you for the introduction and thank
you for inviting me here and thank you
everyone for coming to my talk
um so today I would like to talk to you
about the problem where we use this the
case have been packing formulation but
it's motivated by server utilization
problems in a Computing system okay I
don't have many slides so I hope I can
just get across the main ideas I we have
and I hope they can be useful to
problems you've been working on like in
some way okay so let's get started so
this is uh like I said this is the
passive impacting formulation so the
overall setting is like this so we have
like items arrived to the system over
time and uh whenever a item arrives we
need to give it to a bin immediately and
in this system we have an infinite
number of bins at our disposal okay and
uh each bin has a capacity M so like in
indicated by the width here and uh yeah
so we're going to see like how this
capacity plays a role okay
um and the country like uh in Daniel's
talking he uh sticked to the abstract
formulation but here I'm going to do the
opposite I actually I'm going to switch
to the actual application we are
thinking of okay and the talk about
things in that way so in our application
the items will be jobs okay so they come
into the system over time and the bins
will be serversed and the capacity will
be the resource capacity of each server
think of it as like the number of CPUs
if server has okay and now in the
traditional job model
um so each job will have a fixed fixed
the size fix the resource requirement
and throughout the whole time the job is
in the system it has this fixed like uh
determined beforehand resource
requirement okay
um but I guess here even with the this
traditional job model I'm thinking of
here is a little bit different from a
lot of the bin packing model because
jobs could be part over time so we
assume the jobs only today each job only
stays in the system for a random amount
of time okay so and then like for the
arrival thing we will also need to
assume like they follow a person process
so the system will be in certain steady
state once you decide how to allocate
jobs okay so like in this setting for
example a job comes in we give it to the
first December another job comes in we
give the first server and another one
and then jobs could depart like for
example this job the last the job here
just The Departed okay and now another
job comes in we couldn't fit into the
first uh server so we will give it to
the second server uh and it goes on like
this okay and when we Design This Job
allocation or job assignment policy the
the goal is usually this so we want to
minimize the number of active servers
but the system has a steady state so
what we are actually doing is to
minimize the number expected number of
active uh servers in steady state so
Apple just means like the server has at
least the one job to work on okay okay
so then uh so in our work we are going
to consider oh sorry I forgot to mention
so there has been a line of work on this
previous model which has designed a
series of algorithms that have
asymptotic performance guarantees
optimality guarantees okay I'm going to
talk about the specific asymptotic
regime a little bit later okay and
there's a West like literature on
impacting problems uh Dynamic impacting
problems but I'm going to like skip that
this is the most related line of work
okay thank you
okay so in our work what we are
considering is a new job model so in
this model uh instead of having a fixed
resource requirement the resource
requirement of a job could vary over
time okay and uh exactly how it varies
I'm going to specify that a little bit
later but generally like for example uh
the job here uh like if sorry I think
that job has departed but I intention to
have a job there and over time it could
expand okay and once the job expands the
capacity could be violated but we also
we assume that we can tolerate the
violation to some extent we put a cost
constraint on the resource contention
okay we put the budget constraints we
assume like we now we are going to
minimize the number of active servers
subjected to this causal constraint okay
so this is a little bit similar to the
overbooking model then you talked about
in the previous talk so you could
overuse the resource but you need to pay
certain costs okay okay so why do we
want to model the time varying thing why
do we care about this problem uh sorry
no okay so it's motivated by this kind
of resource used pattern in Computing
systems so basically this is like a
cartoon illustration of the pattern uh
the main message is like this so if you
look at the peak usage the peak
requirements it's much higher but you
only use the peak requirement for a very
short amount of time you don't use that
many CPUs all the time okay
um but if we allocate the resource based
on the peak requirements then that means
a lot of resource we reserved for this
job is going to be idle and then like we
are going to be uh we are going to have
a very low utilization on each server
and then that means women need to have
large number of active servers okay so
what actually what people actually do in
real systems is they actually overcoming
the resources but that comes with the
cost which is like this possible
resource contention right so our
formulation here uh with the time
varying job resource requirements
captures this relationship between
utilization and the uh the potential
cost for resource contention here okay
okay so now let me tell you a little bit
more about our job model so
um I said like the resource requirement
is going to change over time this is how
exactly it changes over time it's going
to follow a Markov chain okay so in this
example the markup chain basically has
like those two main phases the face L
here means like the resource
requirements is low it has a low number
it requires a low number of resources
and this another face is a high so its
resource is it requires a larger number
of resources and uh it could Transit
over time according to those transition
rates and there's a special phase that
denotes the completion of the job so
then like once you enter this phase like
that's a that's absorbing phase you're
never going to leave so the job is
completed okay so this is just an
example like other model you we could
work with a more General Markov chain
with the different faces for different
amounts of resource requirements okay
okay so and then like the jobs uh yeah
so if a job is in Phase L we call the
Type L job if it's in Phase H we call
the type h Shop and the initial type
like is given uh by an initial
distribution among those two faces okay
and this uh Mark those Markov chains of
different jobs that evolve independently
and this Dynamics is exogenous in the
sense that like it's not affected by the
resource contention so think of each job
as a like a container job or like
virtual machine job it's serving as user
facing it's serving demands that come
from the users so the actual amount of
resources needed is actually determine
the like externally by the by the users
and the one that's going to complete is
also exogenous it's not affected by how
we schedule them okay
okay so then uh um as a I think I've
mentioned this we will assume the jobs
come into the system following your
personal process okay
okay so now I have specified like uh all
the parameters basically of this problem
let's think about the problem a little
bit okay so this is the system where we
are looking at and if we uh look at it
directly the state will consist consists
of like all the uh number of jobs of
each type on every server so we are
going to have a lot of states right the
state Space is really large so which
makes it harder to optimize over and uh
potentially also harder to to implement
if we want to do a optimal policy just
over like directly over the whole state
space okay so we have to have some way
to reduce the dimensionality here and
here's a common approach
um like a common like a commonly used in
the queue in literature so what we are
going to do is we are going to actually
look at each server we want to look at
each server separately okay when we look
at them separately we want to evaluate
like whether a survey is in the position
to take a new job or not okay so for for
example that this is not necessary
forward to do let's look at this case
for example if we look at the first
server okay it has a lot of
idling capacity right if we give a new
job there
um the risk of violating the resource
capacity might be low okay so we might
be good on that front however like if we
don't allocate this job to server one
server one may empty like very quickly
because it only has has one job in
service right and if it entities then we
have one fewer like active servers but
if we give this job to server one then
like it will take longer to empty so we
may not be reducing the number of active
servers in that sense okay but for the
second server this job will fit nicely
into the second server but those jobs
could expand right if we expand them we
evaluated the capacity then like it's
hard to say like whether we really like
it we will be still like uh within our
budget or not okay
does it start changing after the
assignment or
yeah like when it comes in it has an
initial face like you know that
initially it uses this map of resource
and it will start like evolving
according to the Markov chain even when
it's in the queue there's no queue in
the system so whenever a job comes in
you need to assign it immediately and it
will start involving
and if you don't understand it like if
you can choose not to decide I will
always assign it because the model is
like I have an infinite number a number
of servers so the direction I was like
it so nowadays like the number of
servers is usually not the bottleneck
you all can always serve one oh server
one more server on okay
[Music]
any other questions on the on the model
is
[Music]
a pre-specified
yeah is it like the expected
um yeah it's still expected expected
cost yeah expected costs a rate to
actually cause the rate over time
uh I have a question like in the
previous page it seems like you're
assuming the markovian of the transition
so yes there are any like uh
justification
uh it's not like a direct if you what
justification I have is like this okay
so right now it's Marco means it seems
like for example if you are in this
phase the time it takes you to complete
is an exponential distribution right but
we could potentially like make
multi-faces out of the same resource
requirement then the finishing time will
be like a face type distribution which
can approximate basically uh many
distributions uh like a stands in the
distribution class so in that way we
could have made this more General but
there's some caveat to it but like it
has the potential to be generalized
right now it's a microwave model
foreign
[Applause]
jobs in the service expand and do
violate the entire bonds and go straight
so if this happens so uh we want to
design a policy to make sure that
doesn't happen in expectation yeah but
the temporarily it could violate the
capacity in that case we don't kick the
jobs out we just keep it there and
except for the rule that that period of
time okay so this is like like when
sometimes the resources is indeed
overused then the server will be in like
under suggests but it will be fine if
it's not too much
but one server that's violated by two
versus two servers each valued by one oh
yeah that's a good question so actually
later we kind of assume our leverage
like if you pay the server out of other
servers even before they add to random
kind of thing and then like a per server
cost it's not
violated but that's a that's a good
question so we didn't distinguish
between the cases where one service
after small the other server suffers
less that would be like a more detailed
model like I said yeah
okay so let me keep going okay so here
we want to we're seeing okay to reduce
the dimensionality of this problem uh we
may want to evaluate each server
separately and then like give a job to
them okay and decide how we want to
allocate the job so basically you can
think of analogy which like this is a 3D
this together is a 3D manager okay and
those servers are the employees and the
manager really like really wants to hire
as few employees as possible and so the
manager is trying to like overwork each
employee but if each employee can only
take like so much so you cannot violate
like the capacity constraint okay so
keep this analogy in mind we will
actually come back to it a little bit
later again okay
um so so uh we want to evaluate each
server and
um and like once we take if we take this
approach we also need to kind of relate
how we evaluate each server uh to the
the actual number of active servers at
the end right okay so uh to realize so
this is basically the approach we are
going to take to materialize it where we
actually we come up with this framework
okay so this framework uh gives so
basically under this framework uh we are
going to take like all the policies in
the original system the original
infinite server system and we are going
to establish a mapping between those
policies and the policies for a single
server system okay I'm going to tell you
about the single server system in the
Nexus live but here I want to give you a
very high level overview of this
approach okay so the approach is like
this when we do the mapping this way
okay we take a policy in the single
server system and we we need to
construct a server in the infinite
server system based on that and when we
do that we will use this single server
policy Sigma bar as a guideline for
evaluating each server in the original
system okay it's going it's going to
tell us whether a server is going to be
able to accept more one more job or not
okay and then like we are going to
relate the performance of Sigma to the
properties of Sigma bar okay so this is
a what we can do with this direction and
for the other direction
um it's more for the purpose of showing
uh optimality of the of the algorithm so
basically this allows us to optimize
over uh this policy class like you and
then still guarantee that so then like
it this uh direction of the mapping will
guarantee that if we optimize it here
and then map it back here we are going
to get the optimality uh in the original
problem okay so this direction will be
more interesting and so I will focus
more on on the on this direction in the
rest of the thought for the other
direction it's also interesting because
it's the converse results so if you are
interested we can talk more about that
offline okay so now I'll tell you you
what is this a single service system as
it's quite simple it's a it's a single
service system so it has a single server
and this server has access to an
infinite supplier for all kinds of jobs
okay and then this server can decide
okay whether I want to have one more job
of certain type or not it can request
jobs at any time and the constraint it
has is still this uh resource contention
cause the constraint like we have the
same budget here and while we are doing
this requesting policy the goal is to
maximize the throughput of This Server
so basically how many jobs you can you
can finish per unit of time okay
um so just as a heads up why we want to
maximize the throughputs like at the end
each server here will be like a single
server in the original system so if each
server is serving a lot of jobs very
quickly then we need the fewer number of
server first okay that's the high level
idea why for why we want to maximize the
throughput of each server okay
okay so basically
bar here as for this single server
system okay so now I'm going to tell you
how we uh like uh what can we get from
this conversion okay so uh although we
we need to convert the policy this
direction but the problem specification
is still for the original problem okay
so for the original problem let's assume
let's still take our example remember
the job is like this okay and the jobs
arrive like the jobs of two types arrive
to the system let's assume they have a
rivalries Lambda sub L and the Lambda
sub H but the time the BIOS together are
here okay and what we are actually going
to do is we are going to think about
this asymptotic regime where R becomes
large so this is to model the situation
nowadays where you have a lot of demand
for your Computing system your Computing
system is usually really big okay so for
people with more TCS background think of
r as the input size of your problem okay
so we want to understand this problem
when RS large okay okay so this is the
problem specification and then once we
are given us yes illustration we are
going to increase the regulator along
certain direction okay okay so once we
are given this now if we have a policy
in this system uh so we want this policy
first to satisfy the budget constraint
that's for sure but the throughput thing
like is like this we consider a policy
whose throughput is also along this
direction okay it's along that direction
and the throughput like for if we're
given a policy the throughput the
difference between the throughput the
actual and the actual rivalry will be by
a factor of n bar here okay so in bar is
something determined by the policy Sigma
bar
okay so what is in bar like I said if a
server acts as a single server in the
original system and buys the number of
copies of the single server we need to
satisfy all the demand here okay so
actually indeed when we convert the
policy we show that this number and bar
will be basically a upper bound on the
number of active servers in the original
system uh however this is asymptotic
optimality so we have a factor of R to
like one over square root over R here
okay just so for the context like the
optimal invert will be on the order of R
so this is like a square root of R is a
diminishing fraction of that okay and
the constraint we also actually violated
a little bit but it's it's a small one R
is large okay okay so in this sense like
once we can optimize Over N bar we can
get a asymptotic uh as in the particular
optimal policy for the original system
and that is like our main result for the
for the problem
okay
so any questions on how we phrase like
uh the the results here
here
Sunday so I should think of the budget
as a rate I'm not a colonist yes it's
actually
it's because the rate yeah I didn't make
that super explicit yeah what is it
about again so once we are given a
policy Sigma bar we can compute a
throughput like it has a stationary
distribution and this group will be a
vector and if we align this Vector with
the original arrival rate the word
differ by a factor like and this factor
is our own bars determined by the the
policy
okay or you can think of this as a
constraint we work with we want to come
up with the policy and sigma bar such
that it's throughput times the by a
number is equal to this and then we will
optimize over all the policies to
minimize this number
okay so uh yeah
sure I know you said you won't talk much
about it but is it is environment as
well on any policy for the like the
opposite so we can come up with the like
if we minimize n Bar we get the N star
that will be a lower Bound for any
policy of the number of active servers
in the original system
so that's why we can get into optimality
because this is lower value
is actually
so still about this constraint uh
so East Denver
it's one dimensional as a number and
throughput is wholesale number
it's a vector sorry three for the four
Type L jobs through 54 type h dots yeah
so if it's not the exactly aligned we
can take the like we we actually just
need to make sure the zero for two times
the Empire is larger than or equal to
the vectors of the demand is satisfied
in essence
okay
okay great so now I'm going to finally
tell you how we actually do the
conversion okay so here's our algorithm
okay uh so for anything any server in
the original system let's take this
server for example we are going to copy
a state to a single server system okay
so this is a single server system and
we're going to run this policy Sigma bar
on the single server system okay so once
we run this at some point this server
says I want a job of Type L okay once it
does that we generate a token to the
original server like the server in the
original system like Type L token here
we put it there okay so we do this for
the all those servers then we will get
like a different kinds of tokens
attached to each server okay now when
the actual job comes into the system
there's a type of L job that just
arrived it checks all the tokens of its
type a chance of the L tokens and picks
one uniformly at random and then replace
we remove that token and that job goes
to that server okay so yeah let's come
back to the greedy manager example
um or you can think of like the schedule
as the department had and those servers
as faculty members or like the scheduler
as your phdo advisor and those are PhD
students pick any example like you feel
like you can relate to okay so in this
case what our policy does is like this
okay so each employee here they will
look at their own stage okay and there's
some Oracle that tells them okay so now
it's time for you to take one more job
okay once you hear about this you will
put up a sign saying okay I want a job
of Type L and I volunteer for this kind
of jobs and now like the manager when
the managers job is simple when the
actual job comes into the system the
manager just looks at all the volunteers
for this job and depicts one like
uniform net random okay and if there are
like nobody who there's no there are no
volunteers then the manager is forced to
like ask for someone who has been
inactive for a certain time like who
didn't get paid previously okay so then
like the payment of course the manager
doesn't really want to do that right
okay
okay so um yeah so although like this
this is a really good system for the
manager maybe not like it's a good for
the employees but luckily here we're
only overworking the servers not like
actual human Okay so okay so now this is
how the algorithm Works let's think
about intuitively with those tokens how
is the throughput of each single server
system related to the number of active
servers okay
my capacity like can I get the high job
or can I get a low job and then I just
communicate that yeah is this this is
greedy
so it's not so you know in what sense do
you think
I looked at all the servers that can
actually take the job right
but each server like he thinks about its
own actions really carefully so the the
the the the by the I want to take one
more job or not it's determined by a
policy and the potential like we want to
actually optimize over the policy who
like which satisfies the constraint but
maximize the throughput it was like what
does it look like the policy the policy
that at the end we come up with uh
actually like we the policy we come up
with the uh we just kind of form a
linear uh linear program of the the mdp
problem like a linear formulation of the
state action like a frequencies and we
solve that we didn't have like a really
intuitive policy at this point to
potentially we should think of this
suppose the job sizes didn't change so
in just the traditional window I think
then this would become the greedy Birds
or I think that's yeah yeah yeah that's
a good point thank you
yeah the single server policy Sigma bar
is applied to the state of its own queue
what's the its own capacity or its on
The Ensemble uh it's its own its own
State yeah but there's some like nuances
to it I will like we can change more
offline but the roughly speaking is its
own State okay
so it's right so the probability that I
I change my size is uh like does it does
it depend on the problem parameter on
the number of jobs for example no no
yeah
it's controlled by something external
yeah so that may not be the best
assumption
um
it will depend like uh
um
like this it depends on how much it
depends on the like the actions here
like if we think about that those are
things that like okay now
but if they won't describe an
opportunity I would say that like if
there are many jobs there is a high
probability that some of them will
become big right but that depends only
good that depends on the relative
relation between like the expanding
probability and the living probability
if you have a lot of jobs it could also
be like they can they have a you have a
a large chance that someone will leave
will depart like within it depends on
like how relative those rates are yes
yeah
so with the school server problem is not
strictly speaking
assignments
uh so yeah so the um yeah so it's a
little bit complicated uh like like how
they depend on each other right like if
you just look at this single server
policy yeah it will depend on if the
state here changes the state you will
need to also put in the new state for
the signal server policy so the the
single serial policy here is not a
system Independence system is owned
right but at the end when we prove it
like we only couple the Dynamics of
those systems so we don't really like uh
follow along like we don't really think
it's through the whole sample path of
the single server system
foreign
jobs based on the current state not the
history but uh yeah
no no we don't need to look into the
policy that's right and this is the the
conversion part like if we just want to
run this algorithm it doesn't depend on
anything inside of the signature policy
policy so
um okay so let's uh uh just look at a
little bit more intuition for why the
throughput is related to the number of
active servers so basically if each
single server it has a high throughput
then this is someone who is really
efficient at processing things right so
then like uh then it's good like it's
kind of you have volunteers all the time
even if you just have a few number of
servers here they can satisfy the demand
okay so higher throughput will imply
like a number of lower number of active
servers because you have like a tokens
available from them all the time okay
okay so to to make the the policy more
well behaved we need to add some more
details to the conversion part okay so
um so here we add two things so first uh
we only oh yeah I guess this may be
related to your question but let me
first let's see what this is so we we
need to we can run the policy uh we need
We Run The Single server policy for only
part of the servers like specifically
for only a bar of the servers like
intuitively we only need and bar copies
of them so uh then like uh at the end we
will show the that the number of active
servers is basically upper bounded by
and bar so we don't care about the
servers outside of nbar okay so inboard
does depend on uh the policy although we
don't need to look into the policy per
se okay it depends on parameters of the
policy okay
um yeah so this is one part okay we cut
it here and
um another thing is we want to regulate
the number of tokens we have in the
system so if the number of tokens is too
large it's larger than square root of R
we remove the token and we put a virtual
job inside and then the virtual job will
like work like a real job it evolves
over time okay and at the end we will
show that the number of virtual jobs is
also not too much is on the order of the
square root of R across the system
okay
okay and uh okay so those are like the
fixes we we do like for the system to be
more well behaved
um
um so yeah let me explain that that
depends on that that's related to the
Nuance of running this single server
policy so when we run the single serial
policy actually I lied a little bit we
didn't just take the real jobs as a
state okay we actually take the real
Jobs Plus virtual jobs as a state so for
them to work similar to each other we
need to say okay the number of virtual
jobs doesn't affect them much yeah okay
um
okay good so now that I'm going to show
you the first like um the first uh key
idea in our analysis so the first key
idea now our analysis is basically what
I have been telling you like we want to
show that each server here uh is is like
in the uh in in a sense it's close to an
actual like a single server system okay
so we want to show that they are close
to each other okay
um however if we think about like if the
of course if like for the single server
system it generates the requests if the
request can be immediately replaced by
real jobs they are exactly the same
right like that will be just great but
the actual how the actual system works
is like this we generate a request the
actual server generator is a token and
then you need to wait for the job to
come and picks your token to realize it
and then like we also have this
regulation for uh the number of tokens
they may overflow oh and we need to
realize them using like virtual jobs so
it has all the source of those
complications and because of that the
servers are actually correlated together
right when the job comes in you need to
look at the tokens of all the servers so
they are correlated and that's causing
us some like a difficulty here okay what
we ideally want to show is like each
server will look like independent copy
of the single server system okay
so the the the main idea we come up with
is actually very simple okay so what we
do is when we look at the single server
when we look at each server in the
original system
we look at this number okay I tilta
that's for tab I jobs okay it's the
number of actual Jobs Plus the number of
virtual Jobs Plus the number of tokens
okay so can you see how this like it's
just a simple trick can decouple the
servers in the original system
and why when we consider the sum it's
all good
let's think about the case when the job
arrives okay if a job arrives to the
original system what does it do it
replaces a token with the actual job on
the server right in other words it
doesn't change the sum of the number of
jobs and the number of tokens on each
server okay so that part is taken care
of and let's think about the token
overflow when the number of tokens is
large what do we do we replace them
using virtual jobs okay so then like in
other words the sum between the workflow
jobs and the number of tokens doesn't
change like again okay so basically if
we think about the sum that kind of
decouples the origin the servers in the
original system and that like that that
that that is like a makes the proof like
a go through okay and now let's um yeah
that is my question I forgot to show
this question okay so uh and the
arrivals and token flows do not really
affect this kyota and now let's uh
compare this with the K bar which is the
number of type type eye drops in the
single server system and we want to show
their clothes right so one thing we need
to uh uh so what I described is the kind
of the arrival parts of the Dynamics
there are some other parts where for
example like a request to the single
server system and that will generate a
job here and generate a token here so it
changes them like in a similar way but
like I said the state will differ better
number of tokens but we will bound the
number of tokens at the end okay and
another thing is this job departure
process and uh that will differ by
um
uh the the face transition everything
compare this with this also like uh if
we want to make sure this is similar to
this then like they differ by the number
of tokens which will rebound like the
number of tokens is actually bounded
okay because the the way we implement
the algorithm we force the number of
tokens to be bounded okay and uh okay so
now we can basically show all the
Dynamics are similar to each other
between those two systems and we use a
technique called the science method to
actually show that in steady state the
distribution of them are similar to each
other basically if they're
um their transition probability
transition rates are similar for the two
Markov processes then you can show that
there are stationary distributions are
also close to each other okay
system
it's so important what you said doesn't
seem to depend on there with two types
right right like I said all the results
come through when you have multiple
types like that's just an example to
help us think yeah
okay so this is the part we show there
are similar to each other and then we
need to kick it take care of the loose
ants back at the virtual jobs and also
uh so so we need to take care of the
virtual jobs part and there's another
part which is like like we said we only
run the single server policy for the
first and bar servers let's call All the
Rest the backup servers so there will be
jobs that go to the backup servers and
we will show that that part like that
number is also small so basically the
number of virtual jobs is small the
number of backup active backup servers
is also small okay so and interestingly
those two things can actually also be
shown at the same time okay so to see
that let's think about this Dynamics for
each type of tokens across the whole
system okay so we we have like let's
think about the type of L tokens and we
said we we basically force it to be
within square root of R right okay so
then when is the number of number of
tokens increase is it when is it going
to increase
okay it's going to increase if the
single server system says we want more
type of L job right that's when we
generate a token so it will increase if
a single advers server requests to type
out jobs okay and when when does it
decrease when does the number of tokens
decrease
it decreases if there's a job arrival of
Type L and it replaces the token with
the job right so it decreases like this
okay so basically the number of tokens
here is doing a random random walk from
zero to square root of R okay and then
let's think what happens if the number
of tokens hits this boundary here square
root of r
what will we generate
virtual jobs right so we will generate
virtual jobs and what will happen if it
hits the other boundary we run out of
tokens what do we do now if a job comes
in
we we send to send it to a backup server
we turn on backup server right so this
is when we generate a job to the backup
server okay okay so then by looking at
this random walk we can actually get
those two things at the same time so
basically this is a more or less this is
a balanced random walk okay the rates to
the left and the rate to the right is
like they're roughly equal okay so then
they can instead basically this will be
a station that will be a uniform
distribution from zero to square root of
R okay so the probability for being at
zero and being at six square root are
they are the same there are one over
square root of R okay and now like think
about the rate of generating virtual
jobs which is basically the same as the
rate of sending jobs to backup servers
that will be the arrival rate uh divided
divided by square root of R and it will
be on the order of a square root of R
okay so that's the intuition for like
why would only have this number of
virtual jobs and the backup servers okay
so once we're taking take care of that
we basically shows that the number of
real jobs on the server is similar to
the number of jobs in the single server
system their distributions are close to
each other from there we can argue the
cost will be similar and we can also
argue like the number of active servers
will be close to the and Broadway we we
and by this determined by the single
server policy okay okay so uh yeah
basically that's like that's the whole
thing I have and to summarize we
consider this problem of sorry analyzing
jobs to servers where the jobs have have
varying resource requirements we have
this like asymptotic Optimal policy and
more like more interestingly we have
this conversion framework that allows us
to convert between the original system
and the single server system and uh one
part like I highlighted in the talk is
one way of the One Direction of the
conversion and we call this our meta
algorithm joined the recently requesting
server and uh like uh it actually works
for any policy here even if your policy
is like a sub-optimal right so it gives
you performance guarantee okay
okay so yeah that's all
um any more questions
it's great
okay yeah what do we actually show here
is like this cute cute I think as close
to the number of actual jobs so the
schedule that includes the number of
tokens at this step
this is not really a mark of change
because of the external yeah I think
this year I'm going I'm just an industry
of this intuition so uh we are not
actually thinking of the actual sample
path and like how it works like every
step for this single server system
because like you said it will depend on
like if things happen here is not the
actual marginal change so what we
actually do is just uh like take this
the generator of this Marco chain and
compare it with the Dynamics of this
number in basically yeah
menu right we need to bound to their
difference like in different ways we we
solve it uh so-called personal equation
like that can translate between the
difference in the generators to the
difference in the distribution
two questions uh so one is uh why not
consider the signing with higher
probability to servers which have tokens
of some type if a token comes in uh have
you thought about it but
the number okay yeah so we picked like
the tokens uniform that random if a
server has more tokens it will be paid
connection uh with the higher
probability
oh because it's like your accounting
server much but
it's just proportionate I don't ever
have tokens right
uh the other question that I had is that
it seems that it's a pretty key
assumption uh although maybe you have
this General deduction that you have
this underlying Mark of chain model uh
what yeah for the job so what do you do
if you don't what what would you do yeah
like if you don't know the parameters
yeah yeah that's actually something I'm
thinking about because our conversion
like like the loop pointed out doesn't
really depend on how the single server
policy works right okay so if you have a
certain way to like it like a train the
single server policy like do it while
learning like the characterization of
the jobs that you you can you can do
whatever you want to solve the RL for
that single server problem then we can
convert it to a multi server uh to the
policy the infinite server system so
that will be kind of advantage of the
conversion but uh as to how to solve
that single server uh problem uh like
that's like
right right now it doesn't require the
knowledge of the mark of change but
perhaps that party can be taken care of
by getting some character getting some
data where you can learn the
distributions of the jobs or you can get
some predictions for the jobs that tells
you how they are going to be involved
things like that so if you have an
approximately optimal policy for the
server problem the approximation error
so what we show is that yeah uh let's
let me just go back
and here
okay so here this one is not necessarily
the optimal policy as long as you
calculate this and work we can convert
it like with this guarantee okay yeah
basically find the smallest 10 bar where
different boys the two times
yeah
you get this further expansion right and
if there is some approximation to the
optimal value of Amber say Ambassador is
the V optimal smallest number we can
achieve then there is an Epsilon Gap
yeah yeah tell me like a recorder for
the paper yeah
[ __ ]
so actually I guess as a follow-up to
servers I was thinking it feels like
your token system
should be able to handle something like
a general Restless bandwidth like you
just need to be able to solve a single
node problem and then the way you pick
the nodes you're kind of saying the
token takes the role of an index policy
I mean I think that would be it's a
really cool policy like if you can okay
it feels like it's like before each
Single part we don't really assume the
full knowledge of yes that is it yeah
yeah I think that would be super
interesting but one quick thing about
the
virtual jobs
so another natural thing to do would be
to put a reflecting put a reflection at
a certain point at like square root for
a random work and just say I I don't
really need to generate a virtual job I
just don't do anything yeah yeah so that
this is stochastically dominating the
system with the virtual job like instead
of doing a generator company say it's
sort of just a dominant skin oh yeah
that's a possibility right away yeah
yeah but like I on the high level I
would argue like it come with you with
the number of tokens with you with like
the backup servers those are more like
for the proof Technologies if you don't
have any of those I think the algorithm
will work fine
um okay thank you everyone again for
listening to my couch
[Applause]